c'est dans cet immense balle de golf que
se cache un des nouveaux radars doppler
d'environnement canada
l'appareil situé à une quarantaine de
mètres du sol permet d'évaluer la force
des vents et de déceler les
précipitations restent on trouve le
christ ans alphonse et la partie qui va
générer longue qui est envoyé par le
radar depuis le début octobre c'est le
radar de blainville qui est utilisé par
les météorologues pour effectuer les
prévisions dans la grande région de
montréal de la frontière américaine
jusque dans les hautes laurentides il a
une portée de 300 km c'est 60 de plus
que celui qui était utilisé auparavant
il est aussi plus précis non verticale
et non horizontale qui donne une idée
sur la forme la prestation et on peut
détecter est-ce que c'était un cristal
comme la neige que c'est une gouttelette
une petite boulette une grosse
gouttelettes donc et où un grêlon même
où les insectes donc on peut savoir
qu'est ce que c'est qu'on vient de
toucher avec notre radar le radar est
l'outil numéro un pour prévoir le temps
violent comme les tornades et orages la
grêle et les blizzards les nouveaux
appareils qui balaie le ciel plus
rapidement permettront météorologues de
faire des prévisions avec plus de
rapidité en avant un scan
une image radar à chaque dix minutes
versus maintenant à chaque six minutes
c'est un net avantage ça va nous
permettre d'envoyer des alertes en temps
plus important donc on est plus efficace
sur la rapidité à voir nos images donc
on peut aussi produire des
avertissements les élèves plus
rapidement environnement canada
remplacera ses trente et un radar d'un
bout à l'autre du pays d'ici cinq ans et
on ajoutera deux nouveaux un
investissement de 200 millions de
dollars
le réseau existant c'est un réseau
vieillissant qui comportait plusieurs
types de technologies donc l' avantage
de remplacer par un nouveau réseau
c'est d'avoir une technologie de pointe
et ouchy une technologie qui vont est
uniforme dans cinq ans les canadiens
devraient avoir droit à des prévisions
plus rapide et plus précise lors
d'événements météo extrêmes ici olivier
bachar réseau canada l'un ville